the compliments from people kind of
raising me for losing weight that I
didn't need to lose it really did like
help kick-start a full-on eating
disorder you know you're on sore uncle's
or your parents whatever might say
something to you thinking that it's just
an observation I know that people mean
well when they say especially like you
look good in every last way you would
think that like getting comments about
your weight and how you look is always
gonna be like a positive thing if it's
like a positive comment when I was 15
years old I was put on this medication
and a side effect was weight loss and
this girl came up to me she's like oh my
god man I want your hipbones
over like a year and a half I lost like
20 more pounds the compliments kind of
stopped at some point because it really
became obvious that it it wasn't good
anymore in college I went through a
really tough time where I was starving
myself essentially people were
reinforcing it by saying like oh you
look like so great like look look so fit
I was not fit I was not fit mentally and
I was not fit physically I lost a lot of
weight like I went from maybe like a 12
10 to a 6 4 and I came back for the
summer like before I even said her loads
of people everyone was like oh my god
you look so great you look amazing I
didn't really know how to feel because I
didn't lose the weight on purpose and I
didn't lose it in a healthy way like I
was just really sad and depressed that
whole school year I lost the kind of
weight after a really bad breakup and I
remember going out for the first time in
like months and my friends look at me be
like oh you look so good you lost so
much weight
I had like conflicted feelings I was
like yeah I'm thin and now I can like go
out and get a better guy but at the same
time I was like well I'm saying because
I've been lying on my bed for the past
month
after I gave birth people are already
mentioning that hey you look great and
hey you know you're already losing the
baby weight a lot of women are posting
their progress throughout their
pregnancy and then their progress post
pregnancy so there's a lot of pressure
to be able to keep up with that well I
created this pressure and this fear of
what happens if I don't keep it up if I
don't maintain it I think in general we
have to take a little bit more of an
emphasis away from the number
complimenting somebody's weight I don't
think it's the best compliment you can
give I feel like not all weight loss is
intentional just just tell them like hey
you're looking great today even if it's
just saying like hey cool shirt you
don't need to make it about weight I
like that when people said oh like
you're you know chest design like I
don't know like something that noticed
my newfound confidence if I'm happy with
myself and it's all good